bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport il est 18h30 comme tous les lundis
si vous nous suivez en direct on passe
tout de suite au titre en images de
cette édition ce week-end les mureaux
accueillait les finales de la coupe des
yvelines de futsal chez les seniors ou
dont était opposé au paris saint-germain
en cas de victoire les rouge et noir
pouvait soulever le quatrième trophée de
leur histoire en l'espace de dix ans le
foot urbain s'est imposé comme un sport
à part entière et cela plaît de plus en
plus aux citadins pour preuve il y a
quelques semaines un nouveau centre a
ouvert ses portes à guyancourt avec
l'arrivée des beaux jours le tout le
monde de retrouver la forme évidemment
le jogging et la solution classique mais
pour les moins sportifs d'autres
méthodes existent comme le water bike
évidemment comme d'habitude en fin
d'émission tous les résultats du
week-end mais on passe tout d'abord à
notre page spéciale boxe éducative
les jeunes boxeurs du boxing de la
verrière sont revenus des championnats
de france ce week-end auréolé d'un
superbe titre national dans leur
catégorie on va évidemment détaillé tout
cela il y en a eu plusieurs au total le
boxing a décroché 4 titres de champion
de france dont 3 ce week-end à la
pommeraye près d'angers pour revenir sur
ce cet exploit on peut parler d'exploit
en tout cas de de saison historique pour
le boxing club de la verrière à sanaa au
ring le directeur du club le directeur
sportif est présent ce soir sur les 7,8
fort bonsoir à vous bonsoir 7 accompagné
de deux de nos champions jeune champion
en la personne d'habiles medjahed et
iman loyer bonsoir à tous les deux et
merci d'être là alors on voit évidemment
vos belles médailles que vous avez
autour du cou un premier titre de
champion de france en catégorie minime
pour tous les deux amine en moins de 42
kg et amène par moins de 76 j'imagine
qu'un premier titre amine c'est une
belle joie et une satisfaction pour le
jeune boxeur peut tuer oui une
satisfaction avant tout parce qu'elle a
une dernière j'ai perdu en finale
interrégionale donc la dernière étape en
championnat de france et ça fait
maintenant trois ans que je fais de la
boxe donc avoir un titre national va ça
fait beaucoup plaisir et l'auto côté
humaine s'était passé ta première saison
sur l'airé la première année c'est que
du bonus pour toi de l'année ce titre de
championne de france ça fait plaisir
parce que ça fait juste un an que j'en
fait et ba remporté sept médailles sa
fille en plus tu découvres un petit peu
tout a dû découvrir j'imagine les
entraînements avec un sale comment on
appréhende un combat afin d'exercer au
pas ce que c'est on parle d'assaut en
boxe éducative c'est vraiment la
découverte totale pour toi non
de votre côté hassan le directeur que
vous êtes j'imagine est très satisfait
de ces jeunes boxeurs bas alors ouais on
en est complètement satisfait ça c'est
sûr
alors il ya la performance ça on l'a dit
un sourd sur ce championnat en tout cas
deux garçons les premiers france premier
club français pense que c'est quelque
chose a souligné
en dehors de la performance nous on est
là pour former des futurs adultes donc
je pense avoir tenu ce discours là il ya
quelques années quand je suis venu sur
le plateau avant avant les champions on
veut aussi que ce soit des champions de
leur vie donc sur le respect sur ce
choses là donc je pense que sur ça on a
bien aboutie et en termes de résultats
on est complètement dedans
ouais si on est vraiment dans le parfait
de shepparton c'était vos objectifs au
début de cette saison vous avez ciblé
des titres nationaux comme cela en
septembre je pense qu'amy madjed c'est
quelqu'un par exemple pour citer lui de
très doué mais alors l'ennui c'est que
dans une catégorie qui est plutôt relevé
et il a aussi des phases où il est très
cérébral donc il est beaucoup dans le
stress dans tout ça là il a pas stressé
et bien entendu c'est passé puisqu'il
avait complètement de niveau pour passer
même l'année dernière il a perdu contre
celui qui est devenu champion de france
enfin en finale interrégionale contre
s'était pas passé loin en fin de compte
qui s'éloignent voilà il faut le
rappeler un même si vous n'êtes que tous
les deux vous êtes quatre à avoir obtenu
médailles ou titre cette année on va on
va les sites et vos collègues walid
rahmani noise
mouche et quand film traoré qui a été
médaillé bronze aussi dans sa catégorie
donc c'est quand même aussi un très beau
bilan comment vous faites pour les
repérer ces jeunes talents hassan est ce
que quand ils arrivent la première fois
au club vous essayez de voir un petit
peu disséquer des choses des traits de
caractère peut-être on les repère paon
ça reste des enfants maintenant des ados
on les repère pas on les fait travailler
on essaie de alors la marque de fabrique
du club elle et c'est toujours la même
c'est le respect du règlement sur ça
on est plutôt bien placé je le vois même
par rapport à d'autres clubs donc
effectivement le fait de respecter le
règlement nous peut nous permettre de
faire de nous faire gagner un assaut
walid rahmani pour le citer a gagné
justement par disqualification parce
qu'il l'a adversaire avait trop de
points de pénalité donc c'est des choses
qui sont à prendre en compte donc c'est
on est là pour former donc c'est en ça
que c'est de la boxe éducative on est
aussi pour les former à un respect du
règlement et ce genre de choses au delà
du règlement vous en parliez tout à
l'heure il ya j'imagine des valeurs que
vous l'aurez plus le cas et ça
fonctionne bien cette année en tout cas
ça fonctionne bien depuis quelques
années on va dire que c'est comme quand
on grimpe dans une montagne il sauf que
là on arrive en tout cas avec la boxe
éducative on arrive dans le haut de la
montagne qu'on à grimper progressivement
progressivement on a construit les
choses avec sérieux et investissements
parce que ça nous prend beaucoup de
temps à nous les entraîneurs et bien là
j'ai envie de dire on en récolte les
fruits même si ça me fait plus plaisir
pour eux pour moi en fait finalement
entre 2013 où vous aviez échoué à
l'échelon interrégional sur certains de
vos jeunes et cette année qu'avez-vous
changé justement pour atteindre ces
objectifs de champion de france
qu'est-ce qu'on a changé qu'est-ce qu'on
a changé peut-être on y adapter on a
adapté une petite recherche d'un peu
plus alors l'agressivité alors ça fait
bizarre qu'on doit dire en boxer plutôt
à la recherche de victoires
je me suis aussi remis en cause je
voyais par rapport à d'autres clubs
j'avais des jets d'oeufs parfois je
présente des boxeurs qui sont meilleurs
techniquement ou tactiquement que
l'adversaire mais c'est l'adversaire qui
peut être amenés à avoir plus de chances
de gagner tout simplement parce qu'il a
plus envie de gagner alors voilà je me
suis retrouvé devant maintenant si on
veut être champion de france il faut
vouloir mais à à tout prix non mais
vraiment tout ça doit être une priorité
alors il faut chercher la victoire au
maximum et du coup avec ces jeunes
boxeurs vous avez envie de les emmener
un petit peu plus loin que quand on
gagne des titres j'imagine que derrière
il ya des projets un peu plus loin un
peu plus à long terme non bah j'ai envie
de dire encore une fois les projets faut
voir avec eux ils ont aussi d'autres
priorités enfin le sport c'est une chose
il y en a d'autres qui privilège les
études tu peux le complètement
comprendre néanmoins la transition va
falloir qu'elle se discute si on passe
en boxe amateur mais en boxe amateur je
suis un autre homme donc je suis pas le
même année hcc c'est le jour et la nuit
les gens sont totalement différentes
j'imagine en images ça donne un ancien
que j'avais en boxe éducative l'an passé
qui cette année fait de la boxe amateur
avec moi il n'a pas duré longtemps
d'ailleurs il se reconnaîtra au bout de
trois semaines à moi il me dit mais tu
es un sadique et je suis dit ah bon et
pourquoi ils me disent ça se voit que tu
aimes nous faire souffrir et j mais
alors pourquoi je te faisais pas
souffrir l'année dernière mais j'y vais
je ne sais pas j'y vais parce que c'est
puis la même chose là on est vraiment
dans une recherche d'efficacité de faim
de résultats d'une recherche de
souffrance mais pourra pour pour
progresser à falloir souffrir le
l'entraînement il confie finalement la
méthode d'entraînement amin on va
revenir à toi lorsque nous avions
rencontré cet hiver au mois de décembre
c'était justement à l'occasion des
championnats départementaux tu nous
avais confié rêves de titre national
serait exaucé aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que c'est pas depuis le
début de l'année enfin depuis le depuis
le début de la saison en fait déjà comme
j'ai déjà en début de mission ça fait
déjà deux ans donc l'année dernière j'ai
perdu en finale interrégionale et lab de
pouvoir réaliser autre guimond rêve de
début de saison ben ça fait extrêmement
plaisir
hassan on parlait il ya eu des petites
choses qui ont changé justement entre la
défaite un terrain au niveau
interrégional l'année dernière et cette
année comment tu t'es adapté comment tu
t'es lit je faut que je gagne à tout
prix ce titre national cette année
maintenant à mon avis ça pue ça a été un
travail
mental mentale mental que physique parce
que l'année dernière j'ai surtout perdu
à cause du mental je me suis beaucoup
mis la pression et comme l'a dit
l'entraîneur bas cette année j'ai pas et
pas stresser les résultats étaient là
d'auto côté il mais non on le disait
tout à l'heure en début d'émission c'est
ta première année sur les rings ce titre
décroché on imagine quand même un
potentiel énorme pour toi tu aimerais
allez un petit peu plus loin de
continuer en tout cas la boxe éducative
pour essayer de gagner glaner encore
plus de type ba agit pas je continue la
boxe éducative mais payet plus nous on
est pas trop le disait hassan paris ce
qu'il essaie juste de transfert boxe
éducative boxe amateur pour l'instant tu
restes non dans cet apprentissage de la
boxe éducative
très bien merci beaucoup à tous les
trois d'être passés sur le 7-8 sport et
encore félicitations pour vos titres et
l'actualité continue pour le boxing de
la verrière puisque vous allez
accueillir la coupe des yvelines 24 et
25 mai prochain et je tenais également à
remercier la ville de la verrière pour
son prêt de minibus grâce à elle on a pu
faire le déplacement
il était donc voilà je tenais à
remercier en l'occurrence le maire et la
ville très bien merci beaucoup à tous
les trois très bientôt sur le site sport
pour de nouveaux assauts en tout cas sur
les rings merci beaucoup merci allez on
passe à notre page spéciale football
ce week-end les mureaux accueillait les
finales de la coupe des yvelines de
futsal en catégorie seniors ou non était
opposé au paris saint-germain en cas de
victoire les rouge et noir pouvait
soulever le quatrième trophée de leur
histoire
le groupe rouge et noir jouent ensemble
depuis trois saisons dans cette finale
de coupe des yvelines de futsal il
compte bien s'appuyer sur cette cohésion
pour faire tomber l'ogre parisien une
certaine pression de ce qu'on joue
contre une bonne équipe de paris cap a
perdu cette année contre qui on a fait
deux bons résultats surtout le dernier
et puis ça sachant qu'on n'avait pas
notre équipe complète donc balisés c'est
d'essayer de faire un résultat et de
faire tomber surtout en district des
yvelines étant donné qu'ils ont perdu
aucun match cette année une finale qui
fait office dommage il y a quinze jours
le club a perdu le moteur de sa section
futsal michel bonvalet l'entraîneur
houdanais a donc demandé une minute de
silence avant le coup d'envoi
mais voilà avec 20000 euros de budget
annuel pour le psg les deux équipes
n'évoluent pas dans la même catégorie si
la première occasion et où dannez la
supériorité technique parisienne fait
rapidement son oeuvre le jeu de passes
et de redoublement us des rouge et noir
conséquence à la 7e minute le psg ouvre
le score rapidement trop rapidement
les joueurs de frédéric de claire ne
semble pas savoir comment défendre et
les buts s'enchaînent 4 0 à la mi temps
les rouge et noir doivent se réveiller
on avait une tactique de jeu en première
mi temps qui faisait que voilà on
voulait défendre en zone est derrière
bon on a pas eu on a eu quelques buts un
peu hasardeuse se passe entre les jambes
c'est des petits buts un peu drac fonds
qu'ils ont mis malgré les bonnes
intentions retour des vestiaires ou dans
ce fait cueillir à nouveau à la 33e
minute pour éviter défaite aux allures
de correction les rouge et noir font
parler leur orgueil ils retrouvent leur
agressivité leur impact et débloque
enfin leur compteur mais les parisiens
invaincus en championnat cette saison
sont impitoyables et plantent deux
nouvelles banderilles pour mener cette
bizarre hein les joueurs de frédéric de
fer inscriront un second but pour
l'honneur score final 8 2 ou dans ne
lèvera pas la quatrième coupe des
yvelines on a eu des difficultés quand
même à rentrer dans le match ils ont
pris directement l'ascendant sur nous
vous était bien en place tactiquement ça
bougeait beaucoup on a eu du mal et bon
droit que c'était la défaite comme lé
voilà et en deuxième mi temps c'est vrai
qu'on a une petite réaction d'orgueil on
s'est dit bon dans le vestiaire on s'est
dit les gars faut quand même joué on
s'est libéré un peu voilà le plaisir
avant tout c'est ce qu'il faut retenir
et peas étaient quand même d'un outil
nous malgré la défaite les rouge et noir
continueront de prendre du plaisir
ensemble sur le terrain car c'est de là
que ou dont tire sa force
le temps d'une après-midi les recruteurs
du stade lavallois club de ligue 2 de
football étaient présents sur les
terrains du club de trappes l'objectif
repérer les talents de demain jonathan
minimale pour les images
il observe 10 sec chaque passe chaque
contrôle de balle au bord du terrain les
recruteurs du stade lavallois prépare
l'avenir si le club effectue la majorité
de ses recrutements en mayenne ou dans
les pays de la loire il s'exporte de
plus en plus dans le bassin parisien et
pour la première fois ces chercheurs de
talent se déplace sur les terrains de
trappes si l'individualisme prime à tous
les niveaux du football actuel ils sont
d'abord là pour repérer un joueur
généreux et intelligent la première
chose on va rechercher l'intelligence du
joueur la deuxième c'est forcément sa
technicité et la troisième donc un petit
peu tout ce qui est dans son sens et sa
créativité même si
sur certaines situations le dribble
c'est ce qui nous fait rêver c'est ce
qui nous fait lever quand on en tribunes
mais il faut qu'ils soient utilisées au
bon endroit au bon moment âgé de 14 ou
15 ans et 27 jeunes footballeurs rêvent
tous un jour de fouler une pelouse de
ligue 1 pour les recruteurs c'est la
période idéale pour repérer les talents
qui pourront intégrer demain leur centre
de formation
une étape capitale où le club formateur
fait office d'agent ça ceux du travail
qu'on fait généralement dans l'ombre
parce que généralement quand des clubs
pros s'intéresse aux enfants faut
d'abord bien balisé de terrain parce que
les parents faut les préparer à ça parce
que quand on a un thème qui suscite un
enfant ça va mais quand on commence à
voir 3 4 comme ça quand c'est un peu un
peu délicat
après trois matches d'observation cinq
jeunes ont été repérés mais pour eux le
chemin ne fait que commencer les élus
vont être invités par le stade lavallois
participer à un stage de trois jours à
la mi mai en cas de recrutement
lorsqu'un jeune signe un contrat
professionnel son club formateur perçoit
une indemnité
en l'espace de dix ans le foot urbain
s'est imposé comme un sport à part
entière et cela plaît de plus en plus
aux citadins pour preuve il ya quelques
semaines un nouveau centre a ouvert ses
portes à guyancourt images de jonathan
lynn le terrain est grillagé il n'y a
pas de touche pas de temps mort au foot
urbain la part belle est faite aux
spectacles aux gestes techniques et aux
buts sur 30 mètres par 20 de large aussi
bien les footballeurs du dimanche que
les professionnels du passement de
jambes s'affrontent en cinq contre cinq
c'est extrêmement intense mais
c'est toujours sympa de voeux
55 ans il ya plus de touches de balle ça
va plus vite c'est un peu le principe
c'est que ce soit plus ludique plus
accessible et beaucoup plus fun
immédiatement les personnes qui viennent
jouer
viennent chercher un plaisir immédiat
n'y a pas besoin de s'entraîner n'y a
pas besoin de connaître la tactique qui
a pas besoin d'être un grand joueur de
foot pour pour s'amuser immédiatement
voir sur les terrains ici la pelouse et
synthétique et les règles minimales
principal interdiction les joueurs n'ont
pas le droit de tacler pour récupérer le
ballon
la séance d'une heure coûte 10 euros par
personne et tout est fourni vestiaires
ballons chasubles et sans oublier le
club house pour la 3e mi temps le
concept séduit de plus en plus les
citadins voulant décompresser à la
sortie du bureau il ya aussi une grande
partie de nos clients qui qui ne peuvent
pas dû à une vie professionnelle
familiale suivre deux entraînements un
match par deux entraînements par semaine
un match le week-end c'est compliqué là
c'est une soirée dans la semaine on
bloque on vient avec ses amis ça dure
une heure le foot après on peut rester
boire un coup ça bloque sa soirée mais
voilà à guyancourt urban football a
ouvert son premier complexe dans les
yvelines le 14e en france
avec l'arrivée des beaux jours l'envié
de prendre soin de son corps est de plus
en plus présente et le jogging est
souvent la solution pour se sentir bien
dans sa peau en tout cas la solution
traditionnelle et pour les moins
sportifs d'autres méthodes existent
désormais comme le water bike reportages
réalisés avec elodie moines
le soleil revient les vacances
approchent tout le monde veut pouvoir
défiler fièrement dans son maillot de
bain sur la plage cet été et pour
atteindre la ligne d'arrivée dans de
bonnes conditions
vous pourrez choisir la solution
classique le footing et quatre en été
sur ce terrain sur ce stade et les ai
pas le tour d'accord
j'arrivais ici à la flore au bout du
fusil je pensais que tout gagné j'ai
fait un temps je suis morte
si vous êtes plutôt sédentaire pour se
motiver les préférable de courir en
groupe avec des personnes d'un niveau
équivalent par dose de deux footings par
semaine vous pourrez retrouver une
condition physique acceptable
il faut déjà arriver à trouver du
plaisir c'est tout le temps par étape il
faut pas être pressé c'est pour ça que
encore une fois je vous le dis il faut
être progressif et s'inscrire sur du
long terme on parle de développement
durable en ce moment et bien faisons du
développement durable sur notre corps
n'oubliez pas les étirements et respecté
des temps de repos pour laisser votre
corps se régénérer et surtout munissez
vous d'une paire de chaussures adaptées
et si vous n'êtes pas adepte de l'effort
intense vous pourrez vous dirigez dans
ce centre de water bike créé il y a deux
ans cette enseigne propose à ses clients
de se dépenser sans le moindre effort en
associant les bienfaits du vélo et de
l'eau dans des cabines individuelles
je suis pas très sport j'aime bien me
détendre et là je fais mais les deux
ont sans rien du tout ça ça pour les
gens qui sont pas trop sport c'est super
j'ai tendance à faire la tachycardie à
l'effort et à rougir très vite et le
côté pouvoir le faire dans l'eau ça
permet effectivement de
d'atténuer ses effets un peu gênant du
sport à l'extérieur surtout sur sol dur
le mouvement de pédalage permettra de
faire travailler vos capacités
cardiaques et ses machines d'affiner la
silhouette à votre rythme il n'y a
aucune résistance sur le pédalier jamais
parce que si vous mettez de la
résistance sur un pédalier vous
transformez le muscle mais vous
l'élargisse et nous nous travaillons
pour la jeune fille nous voulons des
gens green s'en sert et le water bike
favorise également le retour veineux la
plupart des clients disent obtenir des
résultats au bout de trois ou quatre
séances pour 30 minutes sur le vélo il
vous en coûtera 30 euros
on commence ses résultats par du
football 16e journée de division
d'honneur versailles recevaient
l'entente sannois saint gratien et les
joueurs de david giguet se sont imposés
3 buts à 2 et se hisse sur le podium à
la troisième place en promotion
d'honneur on jouait la 12e journée match
en retard dans la poule b et rap
s'incline à domicile face aux montois 3
buts à 2 et restent septièmes et dans la
poule c oui encore 11e s'est imposé sur
la pelouse du quatrième montfermeil sur
le même thème qui même score par dont
une victoire conjuguée au match nul du
peg 10e à eni qui permettent aux joueurs
de jules talmont rose de revenir à deux
points d albi quoi à quatre journées de
la fin de la saison tout est encore
jouable évidemment pour le maintien
handball et deux de chute pour montigny
le bretonneux pour le compte de la 20e
journée de national 2 désigné montaigne
se sont inclinés sur le terrain du
deuxième gagnés 26 buts à vingt les
saint quentinois se perdent une place au
classement et sont désormais sixièmes
foot us dans le choc de cette 7e journée
du championnat de france élite les
templiers se sont inclinés sur la
pelouse du champion de france en titre
les black panthers 28 à 20 avec cette
deuxième défaite de la saison les
joueurs d'emmanuel chars et pointe
désormais à la 3e place il y avait de
l'ultimate ce week end plaisir
accueillez les phases finales du
championnat de france de division 3 en
extérieur après une saison assez
irrégulière plaisir se battait pour ne
pas descendre dans l'échelon inférieur
les joueurs ont réussi il faut le dire à
lancer le frisbee entre les gouttes et
avec une victoire une défaite le samedi
les plaisirs roi termine finalement 7e
sur douze au classement et se
maintiennent donc en division 3 en ce
qui concerne le titre ce sont les eagles
de nice qui se sont en qui l'ont emporté
sont sacrés champions de détroit à
l'issue du week-end en baseball
troisième journée de division 2 pour le
compte de cette troisième journée
montigné recevait vauréal et s'est
imposé tranquillement sur les deux
matchs 9.10 et 11,7 encore deux infos
avant de nous quitter tout d'abord du
tennis de table et la jeune audrey zarif
la jeune pongiste élan courtoise
participe depuis ce lundi matin et pour
la première fois aux championnats du
monde par équipes de tennis de table la
compétition se déroule à tokyo au japon
et pour leur entrée en lice les joueuses
de l'équipe de france ont remporté leur
premier match ce matin face à la russie
3 matchs à zéro une dernière info rugby
et plaisir connaît désormais son
adversaire pour le compte des 32e de
finale de fédérale 3 les joueurs de
philippe bérard béart seront opposés au
rugby-club puilboreau et auront
l'avantagé de recevoir le match retour
grâce à leur deuxième place de saison
régulière en tout cas le match aller
c'est ce dimanche à 15 heures en
charente maritime c'est la fin de ce set
8 fort merci de l'avoir suivi je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur
téléphiles à l'heure du prochain